you know with everything happening in  the world many experts are saying people  should not plan to have a traditional  thanksgiving celebration  well just today there was yet another  press conference from a concerned group  we have some of the footage of that  press conference have a look  thank you all for gathering here today  let's keep this quick  today i speak for all turkeys when i say  it would be  highly inappropriate to move forward  with any normal  thanksgiving traditions until president  trump  has officially conceded the presidential  race  also no turkeys should be eaten until  everyone has received a covered vaccine  that is 100  effective it just makes sense people  and some are saying that six out of  eight turkeys have contracted the  deathwing virus  so thanks for coming out all right let's  hit that dildo  store